let me ask a bit of a human question
charles hoskinson someone you've worked
with
in the early days of ethereum their
peers to my outsider view
to have been a bit of a falling out is
there positive
inspiring human story to be told about
why you two parted ways
i kind of wants to let the various books
about ethereum speak for themselves
um but you know you know if i feel like
you know since that time i think uh you
know charles has that clearly
i mean progressed and matured in a lot
of ways and
people who follow charles closely have
definitely told me that you know like
2021 charles is very different from
2014 charles and i'm sure 2021 vitalik
is much
different from 2014 metallic as well i'm
kind of interested how the 2030 and 2040
vitalik and charles look like as well
oh interesting like the progression of
the humans
is this going to be one of those things
where like everyone comes full circle
and then 2030 vitalik and charles are
best friends
yeah i mean not necessarily best friends
but some kind of
uh um are able to reminisce in ways that
is
um that puts some of the tension of the
past behind
i think so such things are possible um i
think you know people definitely
absolutely have a right to
and and they should strive to just
constantly change and reinvent
themselves
um is there something you could say
about your thoughts about the cardano
project
that charles hoskinson leads they've
worked on some interesting ideas that
mirror some of the ideas in ethereum
proof of stake
working on smart contracts and all those
kinds of things
is there something again uh positive
inspiring that you could say
are they a competitor is it
complementary technology
it's uh there's definitely interesting
ideas in there i mean i do think cardano
takes a bit of a different approach to
than ethereum and that you know they
really emphasize having these big
academic proofs for everything um
whereas ethereum tends to be more okay
with heuristic arguments
and in part because it's just trying to
do more faster um
but you know there's definitely very
interesting things that come out of
you know iohk research and so is there
can you comment on that kind of idea i
as sort of uh
having a foot in research enjoy
charles's kind of emphasis on papers
and like deep academic rigor is there
what's the role
of deep research rigor in the world of
cryptocurrency
interesting i'm actually the sort of
person who thinks d-rigger is overrated
um the reason why i think deep rigger is
overrated is because i think like
the the in terms of like why protocols
fail
i think the number of failures or that
are outside the model is even more
important
is like bigger and more important than
the failures that are inside the model
right so if you take selfish mining for
example like the
the that original discovery from 2013
that showed how
um bitcoin does
like even if it has a fifty percent uh
fault tolerance assuming everyone's
honest it only has a yeah
you know zero to thirty three percent
fault tolerance depending on your
network model
if you assume uh rational actors and
like to me that wasn't that was a great
example of like an outside the model
failure right because
traditional consensus research just up
until
or before the blockchain days did not
think about
like incentivization much right like
there was a little bit of thought about
incentivization there's like
a couple of papers on the byzantine
altruist rational model but
it wasn't that deep it was mostly
operating under the assumption that
you know this we're going to make
consensus between 15 participants and
these are institutions
and if something goes wrong then you
know if it was we can figure out
whether or not it was deliberate offline
and if they did something evil we can
sue them
whereas in the crypto world you can't do
that right and so
like that whole discovery basically
arose just because
like you know the model of uh
traditional uh consensus research just
like didn't cover those possibilities
and then
like once you go out of that model those
that other issues do exist
right um so but then at the same time
like
there definitely are um protocols that
turn out to be
insecu that do have failures inside the
model like this reminds me of at the
time when uh
i think i found a bug in a proposed uh
consensus implementation from
either bitshares or eos this happened
around the end of 2017.
um so that was definitely inside the
model because like they had
a very clear idea of what they were
trying to achieve they had a very clear
description
and like there's a very clear
mathematical argument for why the
description doesn't lead to what they're
trying to achieve but ultimately
what you're trying to achieve can never
be fully described in formal language
right like
this is the big discovery of you know
the ai safety people for example
right like just having a a specification
of what you want is an insanely hard
problem
and like the more powerful the optimizer
that you're giving the instructions to
the more you have to be careful
and and so you know i think
there are kind of these two sides
and then the other thing is that
a lot like a lot of the academic
approach ends up
like basically optimizing for other
people inside of the academic system
and it doesn't really optimize for like
curious outsiders whereas like i
personally met like totally optimized
for curious outsiders or at least i feel
like i strive to
so i guess like that's my case for why
i uh like tends to behave in ways that
you know
occasionally traditional academic types
criticizes being reckless um
but i you know on the other hand you
know there's
i mean there's definitely real benefits
that come from
like just taking us
a rigorous approach especially when you
know you know what the thing that
ex like you know what the specification
is of what you're trying to get
and like you're trying to kind of
improve your way
or provide protocols that actually
provide that like you know exactly what
you're looking for
i feel like realistically you probably
wants to do both kinds of analysis
and like sometimes even want to do both
kinds of analysis and stages right like
you have
you want to do more quick and dirty
things and you even want public feedback
on the quick and dirty stuff and then
later on you formalize it more
and then you get more feedback um like
in general i guess i feel like
the norms of a research in
the future like the internet has just
changed so much there's no way that it's
not going
and you know it's it's even changed like
collaboration structures and like the
patterns in which we work with each
other
there's no way that the correct
structure for
club collaborative research is the same
as what it was 15 years ago but like
what combination of these existing
components and of new
ideas it is like that's something that's
you know totally
legitimate to kind of fight it out and i
think it's great that there's
different ecosystems that have different
attitudes to things like you know i
think
you know there's a big possibility that
you know things that the ethereum
ways that the ethereum ecosystem
approaches some problems is totally
wrong and if there's other ecosystems or
different principles and they can
do well that's something that we can
learn from
you